tout d'abord merci à toutes et tous ce
rassemblement je l'avais souhaité il ya
un an nous allons avoir des ateliers qui
vont démarrer une certaine idée de la
france c'est tout ce combat pour les
idées que nous allons mener
collectivement ensemble tout au long de
ces deux jours et pour les mois qui
viennent donc je voudrais tout d'abord
remercier nos quatre rapporteurs
on a nourri une réflexion qui était
vraiment intéressante et qui
manifestement a suscité de vives pas
dans cet atelier c'est qu'à aucun moment
on a parlé d' aide
on a parlé d'être financière on a
beaucoup parlé d' accompagnement et
c'est aussi ça je pense la droite qu'il
faut qu'on porte c'est aussi non à
l'assistanat et des jeunes ont envie
surtout qu'on leur donne les clés les
jeunes ont un rôle à jouer dans l'union
européenne
ça nous de savoir quelle europe surtout
et grâce à vous grâce à chacune et
chacun d'entre vous
la droite républicaine les républicains
sont en train de renaître
ils sont en train de rebâtir cette
grande maison celle de nos valeurs
rassemblé 1000 jeunes depuis dix ans
c'est exceptionnel pour parler de
l'europe et de la souveraineté brin
nettement yak les républicains qui
peuvent faire ça mais soyez conscients
que votre famille politique elle est
aujourd'hui la majorité européenne celle
qui fait l'europe aujourd'hui
merci donc aux organisateurs de cet
événement de donner la parole aux jeunes
et merci surtout aux jeunes d'être là
c'est présentement faire vraiment croire
en la droite et beaucoup de témoignages
et je pense que c'est pour ça que
c'était important que des jeunes
puissent avoir la parole ce week-end
pour débattre des idées et du fonds
depuis deux jours comment garantir donc
l'égalité des chances et comment
réconcilier république et réussite des
jeunes
quelque sorte ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui ici à port marly de tout ce
que l'on fait au jour
jour après jour pour faire valoir nos
convictions nos valeurs les droites ne
dévie pas une nouvelle génération s'est
levé une nouvelle génération de mandat
d'espoir et une nouvelle génération
grâce à vous seul êtes ici à port marly
vous êtes l'avenir des républicains et
vous êtes l'avenir de la france il ne
suffit pas de dire qu'ils sont l'avenir
il faut bâtir
à venir avec vous vous avez donc vous
les jeunes particulièrement est sans
doute à nous dire qu'on doit aller à
l'essentiel
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui et
fondateur d'un sursaut d'une droite
moderne ouverte et résolument tourné
vers l'avenir
le week-end dernier c'était port marly
une formidable réussite plus de 1000
jeunes pendant deux jours vous êtes
venus de toute la france métropolitaine
outre mer par les politiques travailler
sur le fond les rdj ont été
extraordinaires vraiment un grand merci
du fond du coeur à toutes nos fédé et à
partir de là nous allons reconstruire un
vrai et grand mouvement de jeunesse au
sein de notre famille politique
[Musique]